sto gioco si chiama veloce disegna
anzitutto stai calmo ma devi stare calmo
secondo io so disegnare benissimo quindi
non mi contestate sta roba 3 quello non
è un ragno perché non fa paura per
niente 4 quella bici e terrificante
disegna veloce electro cominciano a
disegnarla o 20 secondi per disegnare
una sega
[Musica]
i sei frayling fan poor's pur al tipo
sta parlando vista dice nissim sta
vedendo fantastico infinito costa rica
recap trucks erno esattamente un pickup
truck con la roma leva quindi c'è una
tizia che tenta di indovinare che cosa
sto disegnando fighissimo no io sto
dicendo una sega però non ho fatto in
tempo una lanterna in meno di 20 secondi
droid 2 di 6 ma poi ce ne sono 6 da fare
va bene gareth lanterna i siemens che
bank o la della luce urla e la bravura
mail interna però no no b day light più
o meno più o meno non venderla sia una
mano con la mano sia con la mano verso
vince siringe store in barba alla
proviamo a fare la barba
questo no questo volti sistenza scott ma
che spetta scopre drums entrato swing
l'aspetta e città è ormai una grossa
questa è una barba grossa ma che smiley
face o i know it's bird brava zia brava
disegniamo all'oceano in meno gli enti
secondi basia so che ce la puoi fare vai
vai peppa indovina sto c'erano easy line
line pro un po più c'è tanta line si
ripete ma che arriva il più grosso ma
che avrò know it social brava zia
questore che paga e sfigata che ti dò io
le cose mettessimo vita quanto l'artista
disegna un granchio va bene pronti
segnare un granché in meno di 20 secondi
regalo come si segna un granchio si
provoca che non lo so come il corpo così
easy line aspetta il sì maschito assai
usata aspetta
ormai segno formont online si capisca ma
capito bellissima come ha fatto a
capirlo sarà una merda era brutti era
più brutto granchio che io abbia mai
visto in tutta la mia vita ma la
indovinato va bene aircraft carrier ma
faccia di una porta aerei portaerei dai
balzi a questa i silvi insomma share
continuous walsh poi noto aspetta
aspetta di dover fare tutti gli aerei
pence al pur l'ipsct genere non è bello
sto bene e rovescia su una portaerei zia
c'è il mare entro ma [ __ ] è remote
control pickup truck che sarebbe questo
dai proviamoci
i silos cui devi farmi disegnare
concentri mi fai ridere o no i vari
travis concentra steurs poi know it's
pickup truck non avevo manco fatto le
ruote quanto ti adoro ragazzi la donna
che vogliono essere in grado di
indovinare le cose così guarda che cosa
indovinato granchio che cos'è sta roba
guerra ma in chicchi sco e gag di square
beh non sottoinquadrato quadrato torino
in gara di simili a questa torta la
torta zia e come la farne sto diventando
il fan spetta zia madonna
i sì sono veramente cagare oggi volevo
fare il vino è una torta tagliata da il
pezzo i sì è la fa sociale candeline zia
le candeline zia le candeline che occhio
forza il problema già essere un occhio
chiesa va bene la prima per la chiesa
anzi tutta la chiesa ci abbiamo facciamo
la croce easy line una croce urla dar
pur leger bordure or lipstick questa
così facile church brava brava va bene
non faccio domande banks easy line
svetta all keyboard bolpin sull il piano
ma che piano esistendo italia si capisce
che un gol con piuma che computer pur
band ma che bed bug o farci un barbone
entri in barbone i silva che ha letto i
domini progressi disegna un insetto in
più un insetto in 20 secondi
ok horse tiago pur grassa che graz
il summit ha impresso lo faccio piccolo
animale migrazione grazie
vabbè migrazione animale con lei tarci
postata sorry i clienti gas ed un
inglese perfetto ripetiamo iq di enti
games.it non ho idea di come sia fatto
provo in string vino orcia vano all ex
no questo è da stai zitta iss i
lightning che lightning ora la donna che
culo nelio forma se questo è già un
gioco c'è il bambino a bambino dai o chi
sia una classe cioè dai si capisce con
chi scalinata si capisce che un canguro
dai snowflake perché la maggior parte
così ci sono scritte devo andare ciò che
la traduzione che non li dedica ok va
beh
proviamo ma è già partito i sing sing
sang et ma che zig zag poi know it
snowflake bravissima bravissima michele
vaira partito il tempo e va bene va bene
botto il cap tappo di bottiglia giusto
ormai in a chi ha la recente anche in
rilievo zia mezzo sfigurato i simple
frate una bottiglia i couldn t 6 stupida
car kurt carr car currency occ iscar il
foulard burbank car crack ma che epica
il frate car
sempre alle ulteriori drawing ma è una
macchina come fai guidare pickup truck
in una macchina i sei police car care
basta e care basta lavoro fifa calcio
seri [ __ ] polis
ma di solo card jobs the lobster un
nuovo video capitolo è già partito il
tempo ma firenze è una corriera astrarre
mi dai fasti noti pack insegne
elicottero è morto è morta è morta dai
sex and the city
crocodile è il coccodrillo come the
young al 3 st bucchi e costoso incazzato
nero ed il cazzo add on air l'angolo
drillo un asparagus cazzo è un
coccodrillo bravissima a un secondo
dalla fine l'ha preso com'è possibile
megaphone che c'è megafon al megafono
deficiente o il suo heather impegnati
flashlight no
i sì grace no no no no no dai dai dai
dai dai o è facile
i sì fan qualcosa per la si vede che pur
trumpy tra donald trump it dove
indovinarle tutte tutte le menzogne sono
non me ne vado a casa dog cane ma la mia
abilità nel disegnare i cani e leggenda
isis herck all orco uffici upi or camera
urbana chi ha la rosa eseries tua
un'aula pulping spiegami che problema
c'è nei guai spiegamelo spiega ma non è
problema ai al cervello spiega però
allora flamingo da impegnati zia
impegnati per l'amor di dio ed urss
square purcher pur purr danni sia in
scream l'ho fatto da di youlike anche
con l'alcol ha gamba piegata it flamingo
è bravo a lorca vallo i sitrac
pur source o i know it source brava
complimenti quel così ti volevo arm
braccio easy and orson kyle poi know it
bravissimo che siamo a 2 drill madrid
sarebbe tra fano golf club pur stairs
ormai kraton poi brava brava brava
carica lightning fulmine facciamo una
casa e il bogey
piove piove piove piove piove un
ospitale qua c'è un
zam islam no in pole dance hall è un
fulmine gravissima per ogni secondo
l'istat il corner elbow gomito a gomito
o i know it's eldo 5 su 6 manca l'ultima
rinoceronte quattro gambe e quattro
gambe in sillabe e lunghi corno
ma se sei su sei maledizione questo è
brutta [ __ ] comprime non so come ha
fatto in dominare fulmine che a un certo
punto tutto cancellare tutto mi sono
salvato come cazzo hai fatte indovinare
gomito da questa roba
sei un [ __ ] genio vetta questa
signora 200 milioni di iscritti ma dei
ragazzi io direi che possono durare
questo è bisogno di acqui draw
complimenti zia sei stata stupenda se
non facciano qualche aggiornamento dove
mettono magari più cose perché veramente
fighissimo disegnarle robe quando le
chiede di potrà young che dal comune
sono una cagata altre sono impossibili
quindi spero che lo aggiornino perché
veramente fighissimo grazie mille
ragazzi verrà servito questo video spero
vi sia piaciuto spero abbiate imparato
che sono un artista coi fiocchi e
nessuno deve giudicare sta roba
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cose
deve uscire da un momento non mi piace a
capace di facebook come descrizione
chelsea di scaldarci vediamo non fossimo
video era ragazzi